you've actually brought us to up to a
point where I want to make sure we get
which is the connection between the
financial cert the financial markets and
the quote unquote real economy and and
in Georgia if I could if I could take
this to you
you've made your your living and a very
fine one in the financial markets and
and and yet you've always expressed and
in your foundation and other work have
expressed it's sort of a great passion
for its connection to the to the lives
of ordinary men of ordinary men and
women as you see the this crisis playing
out what are the things we need to do
internationally or nationally to to make
sure that the solutions help real people
look I think we have to start with
understanding with a better
understanding of how final financial
markets operate and what is the
relationship between prices in the
financial market and the real world and
and I think that our current
understanding is is inappropriate that
the prevailing paradigm of what
financial markets are what their role is
and how they function is actually false
and I have very happy to be on the same
panel of it professor Merton because I
think he's sort of the embodiment of
that for sort of a great opportunity for
me to have this discussion is here the
the prevailing paradigm is that markets
somehow reflect the the real world that
that there is some kind of an
equilibrium price or markets tend
towards an equilibrium which would be an
accurate expression of all the
opportunities and all the valuations
that are appropriate to that moment and
that there are deviations from that
accurate correspondence but those occur
in a random fashion or they are used to
due to some extraneous shock that the
markets have difficulty in adjusting a
neutral accounter of reflector of of the
real world and accurate reflector that
there's a correspondence and that is
false and I put forward a different
paradigm which actually does explain
what has happened why it has happened
and it differs from the prevailing
paradigm in two respects one is that
financial markets are always a biased
and distorted reflection of the
underlying reality there's always a bias
or distortion and secondly that that
bias or distortion has a way of
affecting the underlying reality so
market prices are not a passive
reflection but they are an active
ingredient in shaping the course of
events at this so there's a two-way
connection you know affecting and
reflecting and I call this reflectivity
and that is inherent in financial
markets
you